(child grunts)
(light music)
- When my parents are making me breakfast,
they like make a lot of coffee, a lot.
Becaus they're parents.
- Yeah, I once had it from my dad.
I drunk it, I was like,
"Hmm, do I like this?"
- Coffee stops you from growing.
That's why I don't want to drink it
because then I would be like this little
for my whole entire life.
Oh no, it's gonna be gross.
- I don't like the smell.
It's really disgusting.
- It smells like broccoli.
- Uhm, good.
- Ah.
- I like it.
- [Voiceover] Yeah totally,
spit back in there, spit it out.
- It's almost as bad as asparagus.
- Taste like oil.
- My god, that's delicious.
Can I take this home?
- I'm doing one to 100, it would be zero.
- This is better than hot chocolate.
- I thought it would actually taste
a little better than this.